Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Hey friends and welcome back.
Today on the show we've got a recording of a conversation with a Canadian medic named
Brian which is an amazing first name.
He reached out via the St. Fisher's tutoring page on Instagram.
If you're not familiar with that, here's the basic idea.
There's a handful of us who do free tutoring for medics, nurses, and other healthcare folks.
You just send us a note and one of us will set up a time to chat, totally free of charge.
It could be for anything, dialing in difficult concepts, reviewing a patient encounter, preparing
for an interview, whatever.
Check it out at sfcebm.tutors on Instagram.
There's also a few videos we've made of tutoring sessions.
Those live on the Riker Medical YouTube page.
But to get back to this specific chat, Ryan reached out to the squad to talk about strategies
to better articulate himself in the clinical setting.
He's working through a mentorship program or a summative field evaluation of sorts
and asked for help with how to best explain himself, both on scene and during debriefs.
So here goes.
Okay, so you were saying that you're a medic up in Canada?
Did I remember that right?
Yeah, I'm up in BC.
And we have this, for Advanced Care Paramedic, we have this mentorship program we have to
run through.
And basically, their thing is like just making sure we're safe in what we're doing.
For me, I came from another province after I got my ACT license.
So I came to BC.
And then it was, it's been about five years since I've been licensed.
So I'm starting to practice as an ACT in the field.
And they have this, they have this really high expectation that some, that still some
of the older medics hold on to.
Just like a really toxic history of the service of how they dealt with their ACPs.
And one mentor I've had, he's, he wants me to like, really kind of explain everything
that's going on before we treat.
And one of the, of course, one of the other things too is like, just be, basically my
issue is like having to articulate myself in this large group of people.
And talk about what's going on and being able to properly relay it.
Part of the issue too is like, it's been so long since I've worked as an ACP or in
a advanced care level.
And I'm not really too used to working with like 10 people on a scene.
I'm used to like me and my partner and maybe a second crew.
So I kind of get a little bit nervous.
I get a little bit, I kind of second guess myself a little bit and stuff like that.
So it's, they have a confidence thing, but also kind of like, I need to just start talking
things out more and feeling more comfortable with it.
So yeah, I don't know.
I just thought I'd shoot it out there when I say you guys were doing a free tutoring.
So yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
I guess I'll start with just a couple of questions.
Are these things that you feel like you know well, like when you're not in an environment
where you're feeling pressure or where you're like on a scene, like if we're just sitting
here, would you be able to explain them well?
Or are you starting at like further back where you want to start with like the basics of
how to explain them from the origin?
I think if I like I could probably like right now I could probably sit down and like explain
it, but it won't be a very smooth kind of transition, be kind of more long winded.
So I kind of want to learn to kind of like just break down, like break it down a little
bit more to just something to.
How can I put it?
I'll articulate it a little bit better into a shorter form instead of like the whole long
conversation, if that's making sense.
Yeah.
So I guess I have a couple thoughts.
The one is just like in terms of like public speaking in general, just being in this like
on the spot.
I know one thing that like when I went to paramedic school years ago, one of my prerequisites
was a public speaking class, which at the time I thought was kind of silly.
But it really helped me kind of like iron out the skills of like presenting, even though
it's not really what we do in medicine, but you are like in a learning environment expected
to like present a case and also like give reports and calling and radio calls and that
kind of thing.
But one thing that helped me a lot was listening to myself speak.
I think most people are a little averse to hearing their own voice, especially on recording.
I would like spend hours in like the music studio, like the music hall on campus.
And I would like give my practice speeches and like record them on my little iPad at
the time or iPod at the time and then play them back, listen to myself and like take
notes.
Like every time I made a tick, I would write it down.
Or if I explained something in a way that wasn't exactly how I wanted it to come out
of my mouth, I would take note.
And that was a way for me to like revise those things.
So I think maybe there's a way to do that with a particular case.
Let's say you have like a case that you know really well and there's not really a question
of whether you made the right decision or not, like you're confident in that or even
like you're following a script.
Maybe you could record yourself by giving a succinct report or justifying an action.
Okay.
And then sit on it for a bit and listen to it and be like, okay, did I did that sound
right?
And I listened back to it.
And then if not, you can like repeat it.
That might be one way to kind of work through like the presentation side of it.
Yeah.
And I mean, I guess you could do that also for like things that you're not sure about.
Like if there were something that you, I would say there's a case that you had and you weren't
sure about the right treatments, you can start at the very beginning, like take time to like
look on references and cite things and like figure out what you should have done for that
patient.
Okay.
Then work on that presentation side of like presenting that and where you missed whatever
finding you were supposed to get, like come up with like a case presentation and then
reiterate it by listening to yourself in the same way.
An alternative would be to do the same thing by writing.
So I found over the years that trying to explain concepts like in writing to somebody else
is like a good way to refine like how well you understand them.
So it might, it might make sense like abstractly in your mind, but then when you try and put
it down in words and take your time to like write it in a succinct paragraph, you're like,
wait a second.
I'm not actually sure about this part or like this one doesn't quite make sense.
What am I missing?
Yeah.
So a really good example of that, which is pretty basic, but like, you know, relevant
at this point as I'm helping like write a chapter in a book and we're talking about
like low flow oxygen delivery systems versus high flow oxygen delivery systems.
And the, the definition kind of varies depending on where you look, but in essence, like with
a high flow system, you're delivering enough air to have somebody on events and you set
their Fi to it, you know, 0.4 or 40%.
Like it's just going to be that way in order to breathing like 20 liters a minute or five.
Because if you're using a low flow system, you are taking in air from the delivery device,
but you're also taking it in from ambient air.
So your FiO2 varies, but that was something that like, when I went to explain it, I was
like, wait a second.
I don't actually like, I don't think I have a good grasp of what those two were.
Like I could tell you that like a nasal cannula is a low flow device and that like a ventilator
or a biped or whatever is a high flow oxygen delivery system, but I didn't actually know
the how to explain the specifics of it to somebody.
So just like working through that and writing like two paragraphs about that helped solidify
that in my mind.
That's a good idea.
I don't know if that particular example is relevant, but if there's something that I
don't know if you have, you know, if there's something particular that you like struggled
to explain or articulate or justify on scene, maybe an alternative option to like speaking
in and listening to yourself and revising it that way would be just to try and write
it out as succinctly as you can.
And then like from there, you can always try and like simplify your language.
So in writing in general, like you might write like, you know, a whole page, you know, like
a couple hundred words about like what it is you're trying to explain.
You're like, okay, now, cool.
I can understand, but this is going to take me way too long to stay on scene.
How do I deliver this message in like half a page and then like one paragraph and then
like really dial it and try and get one sentence out of it?
Okay.
I think that is a little bit more tough to do in medicine.
But it's often like a practicing just like writing courses in general with like academic
writing and like creative writing is a big idea and like try and bring it down into like
salient points.
And like managing the space, like I want to say what I said in like this many pages and
like a fraction of that.
And you know, that kind of depends.
Like some things it's just going to take longer and other things you can maybe summarize
more succinctly.
Yeah.
No, I like that.
That's a good idea.
That's a, I can definitely work on that.
Yeah.
And then another thing too, which I like, I'm not familiar with your system and how
this mentorship program works.
But a lot of times in a pre-hospital setting, it's okay to like not have a good reason for
doing something.
You know, like we, at least here in the US, like we often shy away from like making diagnoses
in the field.
And instead we're treating based on findings.
So like a basic example of this would be like my patient presents with wheezing.
So I'm going to give a beta agonist.
I'm going to give albuterol because it's a bronchodilator and that fixes the problem.
I'm not determining whether my patient has asthma or COPD or whatever else.
You can, you can treat based on findings.
So that might be a way to like direct your justifications for things in a little succinctly.
Like you don't always have to have the big picture.
You can explain steps along the way.
But then again, like you might be expected to like do all the steps.
So I'm not entirely sure about the context in which you're operating.
Yeah, it's, I spent most of my career operating like that.
Okay, we got a symptom.
Let's try and treat it.
Okay.
But like, what is the cause of the symptom?
And maybe are we missing something?
And there's a lot that there's a lot of people that do practice like that.
But then there's some people that are like, they want like all this information before
we do any type of treatment.
And it's like, well, that's like medic specific.
And sometimes it's kind of like, I'm being marked on the way they want to do it compared
to the way that I would ultimately do it.
It's like a personal preference kind of thing.
And it's, it's yeah, that's kind of just how the system is.
The mentorship system is it's like you're kind of, you're kind of like held to what
the current mentor is doing.
And some like I've had that like, I want to give this medication because of this symptom,
because of the symptom, like, okay, do it.
And I'm like, right now those are like, okay, but what about, what about their past medical
history?
What about the current medications they're on and everything else?
And I'm like, I'm watching this patient having a seizure right now.
And I'm like, I need to do something and I want to do something.
And I'm not, I got to get all this other stuff before I can treat.
And I'm like, I don't like that way of practicing.
I do understand for some things, but certain things I feel different.
I feel differently about.
So yeah, it's kind of like, it depends on the, the medic themselves.
So yeah, I mean, that, that component is a little tough because you're kind of at the,
at the will of the person who's evaluating you.
Yeah.
But one way I think like maybe to manage that is to set expectations like early on.
Like, I don't know if there's like a, like a start to your day, like while you're doing
your rig check, you can like bring that up.
Be like, Hey, like when we're on scene today, like here's kind of my plan and this is how
I would operate.
Like, what do you think about that?
Like kind of like maybe proactively make that assertion that you, you are going to
make these addictive decisions and this is like how you're going to justify it.
And then you can like talk those things out later.
I don't know if that would help or not.
Yeah.
I mean, I find that that a strategy similar to that often helps when you're working with
somebody that you don't work with routinely.
Like for me, when I'm working with somebody that, you know, I don't fly with often at
the beginning of my shift, I always have like a conversation.
Okay.
Like if this happens, like we have to manage an airway, like who's going to do what and
let's, we'll talk it through ahead of time or, you know, like before we're going on,
you know, sometimes we have a little bit of time to like, um, so to digest dispatch information
so we can pull out a reference and be like, okay, like worst case scenario, here's the
doses that we're going to give for this patient.
Here's the things that could go wrong.
And now we kind of like have a playbook and that makes it a little bit easier.
So when there's like, I don't know, options on scene or like you're making decisions,
a lot of it is already like factored out.
I don't know what that like is a viable option in your setting.
It's something that, uh, we, I have tried and done multiple times.
Um, you know, dispatch information is dispatch information.
It's, it is what it is.
But yeah, I do try to make a plan for the call as we're getting in there.
Um, and I guess like, I know if I could try to, if I could articulate myself a little
bit better and sell on that, my treatment plan, um, I could have, I know I could have
been better in certain situations.
If I was like, say it comes back to properly articulating myself and explaining really
what I want because of what I'm seeing instead of just like, um, just treating the symptom
that I'm looking at right now and, um, having that discussion later on, um, specifically
with certain mentors, as I said, like there's certain mentors that kind of like sell myself
a little bit more too, but also how the systems run here is like, they want you to be talking
about the call at all times, like during the call, because we're leading the call and that
way you kind of get everybody else on board.
So I don't necessarily have to say, okay, it'd be like, okay, so it looks like this
patient might be having a seizure.
Let's get an IV going in.
Let's start paying up some, uh, medazzling around.
Let's make sure we get like a sugar going.
Just kind of like talking out like that, even if I'm like, yeah, I think we might be having
a seizure here.
Okay.
Then, you know, my partner's or the other medic or the other crew there is going to
start working on the sugar.
Let's get some blood pressure.
Let's get some oxygen, maybe get the VVM out.
So I don't necessarily have to tell them what to do, but I can at least if I'm like
saying this is where my thought process is, this is what I'm thinking going on.
And this is what I'm, we're going to go towards and goal and it kind of draws everybody else
in.
So I don't have to be like, Hey, I need you to go do this.
I need you to go do this.
And it's like, there's going to be other people, especially strong other like PCPs that are
going to be like jumping on top of that.
Or even the firefighters jumping out, you'll get like the stretcher and the stair chair
kind of thing.
So that's kind of where the, like, I really want to work on that articulation on a call
is so that I can properly express myself.
And, and is, is part of what you're talking about when you mentioned like this idea of
articulating yourself, is it, is part of it giving those directions?
Yeah.
Part of it's giving the directions.
And part of it's just like, like I said, trying to condense it down and kind of talk it out
a little bit more with like being comfortable talking it out more.
So I know some of it's like a confidence thing.
Like I do, I do out myself a lot because it's been so long.
And then like, of course, the public speaking part is like, I'm out here in front of everybody.
And you know, all eyes are on me and it's like, okay, I'm being judged.
I have my mentor who's like trying to keep track of what I'm doing and everybody else.
And so it's just kind of like, yeah, it's like a performance anxiety in a way too.
So one thing that another thought that really helped me when I was like getting into this
is making sure you have a system for how you do everything.
And that way, like if you get lost, you can just fall back on that.
Like here in the States, we like everyone, maybe not everyone, but most programs use
this like template for assessment from the national registry of EMTs.
So most medics will be able to walk you through like step by step, like all the things because
they did it like a million times in medics school.
And then like every student that comes through has to do it the exact same way.
So that might be a thought process.
Like if you don't have like a system for how you work through the information on scene,
maybe like dial that in.
Yeah, that's one of the things I've been trying to work on as well.
Like the way the systems run up here, it's a lot different than I'm used to.
So like I get on scene and depending on the type of patient or the type of call it is,
I'm expected to have a decision within 10 minutes of am I transporting?
Am I going to hand off to the PCP crew or am I going to ride in with them?
Here is the treatment plan that I'm going to tell the PCPs to do on the way in.
Or is this going to be like, this is my patient, you guys can ride in with me to need the extra
hands or this is my patient, I'm just going to go in by myself.
So it's kind of like I have to, you're right, I do have to like, I all that in and it's
something I am working on because so that's like the new system I'm working in compared
to before where it was like, what I call my patient and you know, I'll have like an
hour drive time to the hospital.
So if I forget a few things, I'll always pick it up on the way in.
So my career.
So yeah, that's kind of one of the things I'm also working on too is trying to dial
that into having more streamlined, efficient assessment.
Yeah.
I mean, one thing that would maybe help is like, if you have a general template, whether
like a, you know, like a rubric or something you use when you were in school or that you
can like just track down from like, you can use the National Registry one, maybe like
use that as a template and then work through a practice case.
Like any like EMT or paramedic book probably has like cases in the back of the chapters
or the start of the chapter where they summarize it.
And maybe just like with that template, work through those cases and then like think about
it and then you could either like write it down and then try and make that more concise
or like record yourself saying it out loud and listen to it or do some combination, like
maybe writing it the first time and then speaking it and then, you know, going back and forth.
I think that might be a way to, to get reps in on that process.
Another thing is that a lot of like, I see this like in the instruction side of things,
like a lot of instructors and I assume a lot of mentors or preceptors in your setting have
like specific things that they, that they focus in on.
So for example, like in your case where you had a patient who was seizing and you wanted
to give a medication for the seizure, they have like things they want to know, like,
Oh, did you consider this?
You could even like maybe come up with like a framework for like, you know, like my most
common drugs that I give or like the emergency drugs that I have, like what's the worst case
scenario if I give this?
So at least every time I give this medication, okay, like, like a benzo for, for seizure,
like I'm going to give this patient for a SED or a medazolam.
The worst thing that can happen is this patient stops breathing, but that's okay because you're
here with me and we have a BVM and we can handle it.
So I'm going to go ahead and give it.
And that shows that you recognize that there are like consequences to doing anything you
want to do, but that you've got it covered.
And like, maybe you didn't like run through a checklist of like, what are my patients,
medications and allergies and like any interactions, but you like, you know that the worst case
scenario you got it covered and you're like, all right, well, all right, that's fine.
So yeah, I guess I'm, I don't know.
I mean, I think the benzo one is like pretty obvious, but yeah, that might be like just
a thought experiment to like work through what, what you do carry or what you like commonly
give and I don't know.
Okay.
Yeah, I like that.
That's a good idea.
I mean, I do think it is, I think it's unrealistic to expect anyone like even in a, like an experienced
clinician to be able to like rattle things off systematically on the fly.
But the point I think of people like leaning in on that concept is that you just have to
think about it in general.
Like you have to consider something.
You don't have to be able to like hit everything.
But a lot of times what we're looking for on like the instructor side is that you at
least consider that other things could be going on.
So yeah, I can maybe that the words they're saying are like, Oh, you like you didn't consider
X, Y, and Z.
But really what they're with the idea is that like you didn't explain that you were considering
something at all.
Yeah.
And I see that often with instructors where you notice like one thing, but when they try
and explain it, it turns into something that's like, like a multi-part process or like many
things.
But really if you have like the one, like one specific thing, it would have like alleviated
their concern that you didn't know the thing.
So yeah, again, that's like speaking very general terms, which may or may not apply
to like specific people you're working with.
But that could be one, one strategy, I think.
Yeah, I like that.
Yeah, it's a good idea.
Yeah.
And then I guess like the last thing is like if there are specific things that you like
don't know, if you've like caught yourself freezing up on like specific drug doses or
algorithms or something, at some point as a student, you just have to like rote memorize
those things as a clinician in practice.
Like once you're past all like the initial like onboarding bullshit, you can always look
things up.
But as you don't really get that option, which is, I mean, I think it's fine.
It's like, it's important to like work through that process.
But in the meantime, while you're in that like learning your mentorship environment,
like you may just have to like go old school and like make no cards or write algorithms
down over and over until you just have it rote memorized.
But those might be ways to work through that.
Like if you don't really have to like dig in your in your memories and like through
the network in your brain to like find out what comes after step three in your like chest
pain protocol, like if you just know it cold, then it like use that mental space to like
focus on like how to deliver your message that you want to say.
Yeah.
So like one thing that I've used a lot lately is I use the app on my phone to make no cards.
It's called an Anki app.
So I use it like I'm in school at the moment.
So for like as I work through classes, if there's things that like I get wrong that
I want to remember, I just like make more card.
I also have like decks for like all different things like for all of my cards or all my
drugs that I carry at work.
I have no cards for for all the drugs that are like mentioned in my protocols.
I have no cards for and then periodically when I have downtime, I can like flip through
them.
And in my situation, it doesn't it doesn't matter so much because I always have the ability
to to reference, you know, because I'm like past that like onboarding process.
But I have find it quite helpful when there's like weird drug doses that we don't see that
often just like being able to know them off the top of my head so I can focus on like
troubleshooting whatever's going on without having to take mental space away from the
patient to go look something up, even though even though it is permissible.
It just like helps me navigate the scene a little bit more smoothly.
So yeah, I mean, I guess those are the like the three ways that I've I guess the two
main ways that I've studied a lot is like doing no cards.
I used to do just writing them by hand.
And now I tend to do them like on my phone.
The other way is just like writing down protocols over, like I'll literally go through like
a stack of paper.
Like when I was in medics, I would just flip through like our state protocols one page
at a time like try and write the algorithm from memory, and then look back and fill in
the blanks that I missed and then flip the page into the next one and just like over
and over for hours and hours.
It's a very inefficient way to learn.
I think there probably are better ways to do it.
But in the absence of like a well structured program, that's something that you can do
on your own at home.
Like all you need is a paper and pencil.
Yeah.
Or you do it on a computer.
You're like, you don't have to kill trees.
You could just like type it out and then delete it and type it out again.
I've never actually done that, but I guess it would work here.
Yeah, feel strongly about the paper use.
Yeah, I went through our protocols and I've like I basically rewrote them into like very
simple note forms just to memorize them in easy.
It's like the odd ones, the ones we don't use a lot to just do quick references on as
well. So we have something similar to that.
Yeah. And another thought on that note is that you could also like you took your protocols
and you like kind of summarize them on a note card.
You could consider like really like reading those out loud or like reciting them from
memory until you get it concise.
And that might also help with you like identifying like, I guess, articulating your treatments
on scene because then you have like the verbiage from the protocols.
I actually I'll send you a link, but I have a podcast that I did with a friend of mine
a year or two ago now.
And he was talking on the show about how he did something very similar.
He called it like making scripts.
He like made these like audio scripts for all of his protocols as his like onboarding
process. And that way he could just like remember them in order to pass his like, you know,
it seems like a process similar to yours to pass his like onboarding situation.
But now even as a reference, he has all those protocols recorded on audio files.
So if he's like driving into work or something, he just like has them available.
Okay.
And I've done something similar for like I have similar scripts that I've made for like
high risk procedures where I work.
Like I have one that I like routinely will listen to on my way into shift.
And it walks me it's like my own voice walking me through the steps of how we would do an
RSI in the in the ideal situation.
So everything from like where in my bag my drugs live and my equipment lives to like
what I'm going to have different people do.
And it's just like my way of practicing the thing when all I have is like just just me
and myself, like I don't have like all the equipment.
It's a way to like visualize yourself working through it.
So yeah, I guess, you know, there's another potential way.
Yeah, I like that the recording myself.
I'm gonna I think I'm going to try that out.
I'll make a note to send you a link there.
Perfect.
Thanks.
So I guess like, I don't know, I don't want to overwhelm you with options, but I hope
some of that is helpful.
Yeah, no, it's good.
It's yeah, there's some stuff I thought about doing before, but there's a lot of you gave
me a lot of good ideas and how I can use it for myself.
Like I have like an hour I want to have drive to work every day when I go to work.
So I got lots of time.
I listened to a lot of podcasts.
So I got lots of time to listen to myself ramble on about whatever the key, whatever
I'm working on or need to put up on.
And yeah, I think it's great ideas.
A lot of really good ideas there.
Right on.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah, I mean, I definitely hope it helps.
And yeah, I guess I would maybe from all the things you talked about, just like pick one
or two strategies.
You want to like overwhelm yourself and try and do like 14 ways to like get to one end.
Yeah.
But it is okay to switch it up.
Like I will, you know, I tend to like switch up my style of studying or like how I'm going
about learning things periodically because you do get like stuck in a rut.
But I would say for now, like if the audio recording thing seems like the way to go,
like maybe, yeah, like maybe tonight you just record like one one script for one scenario
or one thing you've been thinking on or that you got stumped on last shift and then just
like listen to it on your way to work tomorrow and then think about it for a bit and listen
again and like eventually you can refine that idea.
I think that's a good way to start that process.
Yeah, I think so.
Right on.
How much do you have in the in your mentorship?
Is there a set timeline or is it just until they feel like you're ready?
Like there's four milestones.
I started my third milestone last block and the the I'm in medium support for the milestone.
So it's five blocks until I go from my review.
They see how well I'm doing if I need to extend a little bit longer, which sometimes
it happens or if they feel like I've accomplished the goal set out for me in that in that block.
And then I move on to the fourth one.
And then after that, it's just I get my wings and I'm on my way.
And each mile like the three milestones is how they grade you on your calls and how well
you're doing.
If you're dependent, assisted and independent.
So this third milestone, I have to have at least 70 percent assisted.
And that's like needing a little bit of like encouragement to do this or, you know, like
they have to kind of push me a little bit in one direction or like independence.
Just like do it all on your own and yeah, without any really too much, without too much
help. Like, you know, there's there's help.
Like we have a phone line we can call to be like, hey, I'm not sure about this.
What about this dosage is I need some help on this or, you know, that's acceptable.
That's what they want.
And also, if I'm working with an ACP partner, it's like I can talk to my partner about it,
but they just don't want, you know, us to be like totally reliant.
Because sometimes they don't have an ACP partner.
Sometimes a PCP partner and my only partner at my ACP partner is following the phone line.
So yeah, that's kind of how they work it out.
And it's a little on the subjective side, but yeah.
I mean, I don't know if there's like a more objective way to do those kind of things.
Like not really.
Clinical training program has this conundrum where you're kind of in this limbo area where
you're at the mercy of someone else.
And sometimes it's tougher than others just based on like temperament and personality.
Yeah.
But yeah, no, but I've enjoyed it.
It's yeah, I've learned a lot and just kind of like seeing how other people handle certain
calls and it's been quite nice.
So I can't complain too much.
Yeah, well, it definitely seems like you're on the right track with at least like, I mean,
many people make it through school without ever even like considering like how to do
the thing better.
They're just like powering through it.
So I mean, the fact that you were able to take a step back and then okay, like how can
I refine this process?
I've been like, I articulate myself better.
I think is a really good like step along the way.
A lot of people don't ever do that.
I took like a medical before I like thought about like how I spoke to patients like on
a scene or like how I interact with other people because I was like so focused in on
like memorizing things.
Like I didn't have a lot of self-reflection in that like communication side.
So I don't know.
Everyone comes about like about a different way, but I think it's awesome that you're
having this conversation at this point.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah, it's been difficult, but you know, it's like I'm used to talking to a bunch of prairie
farmers out in the middle of Manitoba.
Now I'm here with, you know, Laura Mainland, BC, and it's just like different populations,
different people.
And some people don't like the way I've talked in the past and it's like, all right, then
I got a, I've been told I sound like an asshole or whatever the case may be.
I have to do something different.
I have to change myself.
I can't change the rest of the population.
So yeah.
Well, definitely.
Yeah.
Definitely reach out again, either through the channel or you got my number now.
And yeah, if you need a hand with anything at all, just let us know.
We'll do.
I really appreciate it.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick, before we go, just a few shout outs.
First is to Pragmatic Paramedics, another awesome podcast that we highly recommend.
Next is to the St. Fisher Church of Evidence-Based Medicine.
If you don't follow them already, definitely check them out.
These guys, both Pragmatic Paramedics and the St. Fisher folks have been instrumental
in getting our stuff out there into the world and we truly appreciate that.
And then we'll end things with a shout out to my good friend, Josh Pittman and his buddy,
Kevin Pons.
They put the music together for the show.
Until next time.